they go back a long way those two Thorin
locate they have they have a very
complex and interesting relationship
Taylor was great he's really smart he's
got a really good vision for the film
and I mean thought is gonna be bigger
than the first one you know he's all
over it and they're both still alive and
still capable of feeling things they
continue to to play that set of tennis
whatever it is it's another violent
world on an epic scale what we've done
this time is it it's you haven't seen
this before you really haven't been not
in thorn on in Avengers it's a new thing
he wants to be disappointed leaves me
fantastic comedy side of it's great
there's lots of action as always you
know there's fights is what you know
it's huge the CG he's gonna be fantastic
so I think it's definitely gonna be up
there with you know that the Avengers
and I man 3 alan is amazing he has this
extraordinary breadth of vision really
about about the world
the dark world just the scale of it what
he imagined Asgard to be what the depth
of and and the specificity of his
imagination about
extending the reach of the film and
taking the audience into into parts of
the Thor universe that they haven't seen
yet and I found that really excited
we're in this huge Hall here and that
the sets forth or with this height you
walk in and I'm 656 and I feel tiny but
Loki's the Norse god of mischief and
therefore capable of guile and deception
and manipulation and charm and
provocation so yeah he's got his fire
crackers after so I'd like
somehow low key to get his Redemption
you think you'd have to do to get that
Redemption either by saw all the pop
tarts in the world oh good maybe he
could join The Avengers to fight crime
mmmm